welcome to horace hobbies the channel
will be discussed the latest tech news
and dove into newest tech products today
we're taking a look at the truth behind
why in the media hasn't revealed there
are 1100 series yet but before we delve
into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and PCs so as you
guys already know there was a lot of
demand for Nvidia graphics cards because
of the cryptocurrency mining craze along
with more gamers and NVIDIA wasn't even
close to meeting the market demand and
NVIDIA has been telling us for very many
months that they have been working very
hard in order to increase production and
meet market demand well according to his
new news they definitely weren't lying
about that but unfortunately the efforts
are way too late wait what happened
first of all well one of Nvidia's major
OEMs returned 300,000 GPUs backed Nvidia
not because there were any defects or or
anything but because they simply didn't
feel that there was that much demand for
their GPUs now this is just one om and
the only one that came out 2 news but
who knows if other board partners like
MSI ebj Asus and Giga Byte also returned
their GPUs back to Nvidia because they
had too much of it but whether those
companies did or not Nvidia is
definitely in a sticky situation with
abundant inventory if you are wondering
why GPU prices are still dropping so
slowly even though there is such an
abundant inventory of GPUs for Nvidia
then make sure to check out my dedicated
video on that but anyways what seems to
be happening here is that nvidia highly
overestimated the market demand and now
they have more GPUs than they can
actually sell and this issue may be why
Nvidia is reluctant to tell us about the
next series of GPUs if they tell us
about that
then it would become official that the
gtx 1100 series is coming soon and that
would make it very hard for them to sell
these GPUs because why would someone buy
a GPU that is pretty much officially
outdated this may be why mr. Jensen Wong
the CEO of Nvidia made that comment at
Computex saying that the next generation
of GPUs from Nvidia weren't coming out
for a long time from now he may have
said this for two reasons one he doesn't
want people to stop buying ten series
cars in anticipation for the next series
or two they have decided that they are
not going to release the next series of
GPUs until their current inventory is
exhausted and obviously the sales aren't
doing as well as they expected so it may
take a long time for these GPUs to sell
out and as a result a long time for the
next series of GPUs to come out at first
maybe in video was planning on releasing
the 1100 series in July and even
revealing it at Computex just like
expected this actually makes a lot of
sense considering how GD dr6 memory
production was set to start in June and
how it has already been two years since
the temp series came out so it makes
sense for a refresh however once Nvidia
saw how much extra inventory of ten
series cars they had they may have
changed your mind and delayed the
release of the 1100 series and that may
be why mr. Huang made that comment and
why we haven't heard anything about the
1100 series from Nvidia themselves so
what exactly does this mean for us well
unfortunately this may mean that the gtx
1100 series may get delayed or maybe it
is already delayed and nvidia simply
just won't tell us anything until they
are satisfied with their 10 series
inventory level so should you just go
ahead and buy a 10 series cart because
the 11 series cards may not come as soon
as originally anticipated no definitely
not the 1100 series is definitely really
close and probably even ready for launch
and NVIDIA is just holding them back for
a certain reason whether it's because of
access inventory or just because they
can simply make more money off the 10
series card because they have no
competition
but despite the reason they are
definitely holding a back on purpose and
it is not because it is not ready for
launch so as a result the gtx 1100
series is still really close to launch
and in fact gamer mode actually got a
leak from an insider who told him that
the
1180 was going to come out on July 30th
and gamer Mel is very confident that
this is accurate
therefore the 1100 series is still
coming really soon and you guys should
just wait for that and buy that instead
of buying a 10 Series card right now
overall NVIDIA seems to have highly
overestimated the market demand for
their 10 series cards and as a result
they may still have a lot of abundant
inventory of a 10 series card and this
may be why we haven't heard anything
from Nvidia about the 1100 series and
they may even delay it because of this
however despite this you guys should
still wait for the 1100 series instead
of just buying the 10 series right now
because at this point it really is just
a matter of time before the 1100 series
comes out because the 11 herda series is
definitely ready for launch and Nvidia
just holding it back but that's just
what I think what do you guys think do
you think Nvidia is going to delay the
launch of the 1100 series and why do you
think they haven't said anything about
the 1100 series yet make sure to comment
down below what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
like this video then make sure drop a
like and hit that subscribe button if
you guys would like to see more videos
just like this one but until next time
bye
[Music]